bonjour je suis tel c'est ensemble que
nous allons découvrir l'histoire du
soulier
[Musique]
dans histoire de souliers nous allons
explorer l'univers de la chaussure
féminine de l'escarpin à la ballerine en
passant par la chaussure compenser les
bottines les bottes les mary jane
les cuissardes et toutes les autres
et comme les et bette midler donné une
fille des chaussures correct et elle
peut conquérir le monde
dans histoire de souligner je vous dirai
tout sur cette arme de destruction et de
séduction massive les femmes et leurs
chaussures où la relation la plus
fusionnel qui soit avec un accessoire
votre vie tu ne seras avoué car la quête
du graal trouver la chaussure parfait en
chaume ou sur son histoire et les
infinies possibilités offertes à nos
jambes aujourd'hui dans l'histoire de
souliers vous découvrirez la chaussures
compensées et la chaussures à plateforme
comment ces deux types de chaussures
sont ils apparus et comment ont-ils su
s'est déclinée pour aboutir au modèle
actuel avec quoi vaut-il mieux les
porter retrouvez nos professionnels de
la mode pour toutes les explications
vous découvrirez ensuite les conseils de
look et shopping de nos professionnels
qui vous révéleront les tendances du
moment
vous saurez ce qui est totalement et non
et ce qui étonne pas faire vous
retrouverez enfin notre rubrique des
modèles les plus extravagants de la
haute couture et du design pelouse vous
présenteront les chaussures compensées
les plus follement massive et partie
gymnase mais tout d'abord vous avez
peut-être un petit mois nous dire sur
cette chaussure tea party
paris nous avons mené notre petite
enquête dans la capitale pour savoir
comment vous abordiez la chaussures
compensées
quels conseils mesdames
une chaussure qu'on pense d'ailleurs que
tout le talent est remplie l'intérieur
n'y a pas de vide alors qu'un plateau
peur que sont le l'avant-pied vous avez
un patin alors que la chaussure est se
relever je ne suis pas d'être non plus
ça permet de s'en voir moins élevé
portables à l'usagé vous savez comment
problème tout comme les dix cailloux
sont bien cela fait quand vous avez des
chaussures du consejo a pas tant
alquier composer votre pierre à plat
complètement
déroulez dit
[Musique]
c'est la chaussure des seventies des
soirées disco l'esprit délicieusement
studio 51 ou encore les pantalons
fluides les pique niques dans l'herbe
en bref la chaussures compensées nous
évoque une période d'insouciance et une
liberté sexuelle
et pourtant le xxème siècle n'a rien
inventé
la mode étant une boucle permanente
voyons comment ce soulier de voltigeur a
été créé
[Musique]
juliette qu'est ce que la chaussures
compensées et évoque la chaussures
compensées c'est le confort avant tout
puisqu'on peut être ôté toute la journée
avec une chaussures compensées alors que
c'est un petit peu plus difficile en
talons aiguilles nous on n'a pas de
vraie compensée dans le sens où on n'a
pas tout le talent qui va englober la
chaussure ici en revanche nous avons des
plateformes donc on compense notre
chaussure un petit peu à l'avant donc ça
nous permet par exemple sur un talon de
12 cm comme celui ci d'avoir une
cambrure donc la cambrure c'est vraiment
ici c'est ce qui tient le pied une
cambrure de 10 cm ce qui nous permet de
marcher
et en plus comme elle est un peu large
sanou stabilise le pied et ça nous
permet de tenir toute la journée et
d'être super confort est ce que la
chaussures compensées est encore à la
mode
oui oui oui elle est très à la mode aux
états unis elle est en train d'arriver
en france on a de plus en plus de
demandes pour faire des compenser un peu
folle et en plus l'avantagé c'est qu'on
peut vraiment s'amuser on peut avoir la
plate forme d'une couleur le talent
d'une autre couleur le corps de la
chaussure encore d'une autre couleur
voilà comme celle ci et se faire des
petites chaussures bijoux donc la
chaussures compensées existe sur tous
les types de chaussures sur des bases
d'escarpins et non la propose surtout
nos modèles les bottines les low boots
les richelieu on peut tout faire en
compenser est-ce que vous avez déjà eu
des demandes folle une plateforme de 5
cm par exemple oui la semaine dernière
malheureusement non malheureusement on
ne l'a pas fait parce que comme on
travaille sur le confort on part du
principe qu'un talon de 18 cm même avec
une grosse plateforme ne sera jamais
confortable
voilà et du coup la plateforme permet
aux femmes qui sont plutôt petites comme
elle m'a je ne suis pas du tout touché
la balle je te remercie de leur de
s'agrandir et d'avoir un talon de 12 cm
et donc du coup d'avoir des jambes
sublimes galbées de des gens de 1 m 10
comme moi tous les jours comme el ma
can you
[Musique]
de fait
la compenser est vraiment au coeur de la
tendance ça c'est exact parce que c'est
la chaussure par excellence de confort
c'est à dire que dans les années 70 ont
porté des compensées mais elles étaient
un peu lourdes avec socle rigide et
c'était assez limité mais aujourd'hui
une botte peut être compensé un escarpin
peut-être compenser une low boots
compensées une basket qu'on pense et
même une ballerine compenser et c'est
vrai encore une fois véritablement la
chaussure de grand grand grand confort
[Musique]
même si les talons compensés ont connu
leurs grandes heures de gloire dans les
seventies
ils ont été inventés bien avant bien sûr
ils ont d'abord été aperçu en grèce
antique ainsi qu'au japon pour protéger
les pieds de la boue des trottoirs
c'était là guetta
mais c'est à venise au xvième siècle que
l'ancêtre de la compenser est vraiment
née la fameuse shopping cette chaussure
sur piédestal pouvait atteindre 70 cm de
hauteur et garantissez au vénitienne
frayeur et cheville foulée la plateforme
de la chopine était faite de liège ou de
bois et était un symbole de richesse et
d'aristocratie en dépit du ridicule
évident de cette chaussure de domestique
tenait de part et d'autre les élégantes
devant les regards moqueurs des
touristes qui venaient apprécié la scène
la mode des chopines fini par atteindre
la france et l'angleterre avant de finir
par disparaître complètement
au xviiie siècle au profit du talon en
effet on venait tout juste de comprendre
qu'il suffisait d' abaisser l'avant du
pied pour que la chaussure deviennent
plus praticable ce n'est qu'au début des
années 1930 que les chaussures
compensées font leur retour à hollywood
grâce à une actrice minipousses au nom
de carmen miranda
[Musique]
puis pendant la guerre les créateurs
durent faire preuve d'inventivité pour
pallier à la pénurie de bois et de cuir
ferragamo utilisa par exemple la
superposition de couches de liège mais
c'est définitivement à la fin des années
1960 que les chaussures compensées sont
revenus sur le devant de la scène grâce
à roger vivier la mode psychédélique des
seventies s'est vite emparée de cette
chaussure haute qui permettait de ne pas
marcher sur les très longs revers des
pantalons pattes d'eph
[Musique]
plus
puis comme chaque cycle la chaussures
compensées est passée de mode avant de
revenir vingt ans après dans les années
90 pendant le retour du disco
aujourd'hui elle est plus que jamais
présente sous toutes les formes
sandales bottines et même les escarpins
le talon compensé et de toutes les
chaussures
[Musique]
comment expliquer qu'ils ne compensait
se démode pas je dirais que maintenant
une compenser ses allées au delà du mode
donc les premières fois c'est maintenant
il ya huit ans il y à 8 heures 9 ans
qu'on voyait arriver les premières
compenser et dans le presse féminine
chaque année on prédisait que c'était la
fin des compensées et ça continue c'est
tout simplement parce que c'est pratique
c'est pratique et confortable
donc ça va pas disparaître le comprends
c'est qui m'a marqué le plus c'est le
fait un gamin de 1945
donc c'est le compenser avec le
plateforme dans une motifs arc-en-ciel
et îlots raison que ça me sidère
cette chaussure donc ça c'est une
chaussure qui me motive beaucoup c'est
qu'il n'a pas bougé
d'autres faites vous le mettez
aujourd'hui dans n'importe quel espace
chaussures dans le monde et vous pouvez
le vendre et en fait si donc dans tout
ce que je fais et tout ce que j'apprécie
j'aime les choses qui sont intemporels
aujourd'hui c'est clair donc je vous en
ai déjà parlé après ablement mais le
compenser idéale celle qui me fait
vraiment vibrer c'est le dolce gabbana
avec le côté compenser a sculpté au bois
et ensuite prendre dans des couleurs
très vives
qu'est ce que la chaussures compensées
vous évoque
ça m'évoque quelque chose à la fois
quand même de sexy parce que finalement
on arrive à affiner la jambe vraiment
faim le haut de la jambe parce que là on
dirait pas mais on a 12 cm
donc on est haut perchée on va dire
quand je dis oh j'ai l'impression
lorsque je les vois de nos frontières
comme comme une femme parce que vraiment
c'est des modèles pour moi qu'ils sont
cons et qu'on a fait de nos propres
mains quasiment donc voilà je me les
approprier et en fait l'avantagé ce que
j'aime dans la compenser c'est vraiment
d'avoir cette hauteur de talon et donc
affiné vraiment la silhouette en gardant
bien sûr un confort autre que celui des
escarpins et en même temps finalement
avoir quelque chose de faim au pied
parce que lorsqu'on l'a aux pieds elle
semble parfois un petit peu lourd parce
que le talon est plein mais lorsqu'elle
est au pied avec juste un jeu de brides
assez sain on a quelque chose de très
léger et de très très aérien donc à la
fois parfois avec des des plateformes
compenser plateforme on cache ou des
plateformes
on voit ça dépend aussi un petit peu des
modèles par exemple là on voit même si
c'est une sandale on voit la plateforme
alors que l'or la cache mais c'est
quelque chose voilà ses formes la ccd
forme finalement qu'on travaille
beaucoup parce que on trouve que à la
fois donner un petit peu plus de hauteur
et puis tout en étant discret c'est
quelque chose quand même de très
flatteur pour toutes les femmes et voilà
la chose importante dans le compenser
c'est soit qu'ils soient parents comme
celui ci donc là finalement de compenser
on le voit ou soir là c'est plus une
plateforme et soient ses cachets donc
aujourd'hui ce qui est plus dans la
tendance c'est les plateformes et qu'ils
sont plutôt discrète et cachée on voit
aussi notamment dans les baskets ou la
plateforme est plutôt cachée mais voilà
c'est une tendance actuelle et puis
finalement on arrive à la fois être en
hauteur temps restant confortable c'est
c'est l'alchimie qui fait que c'est
aussi commercial
certains n'ont donc la tendance
compensée n'est pas près de s'arrêter
non non non non je pense que une
tendance en général elle va durer entre
trois et quatre saisons la première
saison s'est pas laissée pas les
meilleures ventes parce que finalement
l'oeil et les gens besoin s'habituer on
a besoin d'avoir dans les magazines à
partir la deuxième saison on commence à
oser et puis c'est vraiment à partir de
la troisième saison que vraiment le
produit se démocratise qu'on le voit
finalement au pied tout le monde et que
il ya un vrai succès commercial donc la
mode finalement c'est toujours quelque
chose d'assez lent on a l'impression que
c'est très rapide parce que les
tendances se renouvelle sans arrêt mais
entre le moment on va le voir la
première fois dans un magazine au mois
d'octobre ou au mois de septembre et le
moment on va le voir porter il va
souvent se passer toute une année donc
mais le compenser donc c'est pas du tout
prédéfinis et même je pense qu'on est en
plein dedans
[Musique]
la chaussures compensées et est une
discipline sportive
ce serait clairement la pratique du
trapèze cette chaussure de haute voltige
est aussi sublime que périlleuse et les
malheureuses qui ont fait l'expérience
de cette semelle sur dimensionné garde
un souvenir mémorable de leur chute sous
le regard compatissant des passants
croyez moi j'en ai souvent fait
l'expérience et pourtant le cycle de la
chaussures compensées se reproduit sans
cesse c'est la meilleure alliée des mini
format elle leur permet de gagner de la
hauteur bertinet la jambe et cela sans
afficher un style glamour exacerbé comme
le ferait l'escarpin la compenser est un
type de chaussures plutôt apprécié des
créateurs de haute couture et des
designers surtout dans les collections
estivales
et il faut reconnaître que sa
spécificité d'ajouter de la hauteur et
tout le volume de la plate forme entre à
l'heure des possibilités de création
hors du commun
c'est pourquoi on retrouve régulièrement
cette chaussure dans les défilés des
plus grands comme dans les
expérimentations des nouveaux talents de
la mode référence ultime dans le domaine
de l'extravagance le controversé
alexander mcqueen oraux avec la forme
habituelle du talon compensé en lin qu
revend sur l'arrière il affiche
également quelques modèles très
travaillé avec de nombreuses des coupes
ou encore du relief d'une autre manière
vivienne westwood conçoit des chaussures
à plateformes avec un talent démesuré
toujours avec la touche punk excentrique
qui a fait sa notoriété comme le montre
la rangée de cloud ou le cuir crocodile
bleu électrique utilisée dans ses
modèles
du côté de chez yves saint laurent on
reste sur des modèles un peu plus
classique sur lesquels ces l'empiècement
géométrique de couleurs et de matières
différentes
on comptera ce avec le corps de la
chaussure qui leur confère une certaine
excentricité discrète
anastasia de biche est une créatrice de
chaussures qui est à l'origine d'une
collection intitulée lost civilisation
qui retranscrit le déclin des
civilisations avec des matières évoquant
des formes de vies disparues ou encore
des messages textuels directement
incrusté comme ici des sources de ce 3e
ue dans la série jeune surdoué de la
mode
janina alleyn construit une série de
chaussures avec le procédé de
l'impression 3d qui permet la
réalisation de ses compensées imitant
l'assemblage d'un squelette
parmi les modèles excentrique de unite
hang on retrouve cette chaussures
compensées qui joue sur le contraste
entre une plate forme massive et cette
transparence qui dévoile un talent
intérieur aux motifs très travaillé
enfin le modèle hyper borea que vous
voyez ici a été créée par la
néerlandaise ia bissert fondatrice de la
marque concept ready to fiche en
collaboration avec le designer relais
vanderberghe il représente selon leurs
propres mots
la pente raide que doit affronter de
l'alpiniste renversant non
[Musique]
mes conseils shopping pour les
chaussures compensées et des chaussures
plates formes donc la chaussure plate
forme c'est une chaussure qui est
vraiment pour les soirées voilà pour
l'élégance de la jambe pour la posture
et cetera c'est vraiment une chaussure
qui va nous allonger 10 12 14
centimètres de talons pour les plus
audacieuses on peut vraiment aller très
très loin dans la plateforme
c'est un modèle que j'aime beaucoup en
bleu dans des couleurs un peu
électriques
justement pour réveiller nos tenues de
soirées qui sont parfois un peu triste
ou y voit là on sort rapidement sa
petite robe noire quand on ne sait pas
quoi m et avec une jolie chaussures ou
bleu hop tout de suite le regard est
attiré sur legend ou alors des modèles
un peu plus sabres voilà celle ci que
j'aime beaucoup également en noir
donc là on a juste joué sur les matières
on va avoir du vernis sur le talon sur
la plateforme et du velours sur la rose
sur le reste de la chaussure donc là
c'est vraiment du détail mais ce sont
des détails qui font la différence avec
ce talon qui brise un peu
ou enfin un modèle que j'aime beaucoup
voilà du vélo me base sur la plateforme
est le talon et le corps en poulain noir
très brillant très soyeux
voilà donc ça c'est un modèle qui est
parfait pour les soirées est vraiment
pour moi la plateforme ya beaucoup de
femmes qui la portent pour tous les
jours mais je sens que c'est vraiment un
produit de soirée voilà une chaussure
d'exception qui va nous mettre en valeur
et
et qui va nous faire un peu brillé en
soirée conseils shopping sur la
compenser multi usages multi fonctions
et il y a deux tendances sur le
comprends c'est donc c'est pas juste
2013 on a vu le début en 2012 donc les
deux tendances que je vois le plus fort
c'est des compensées qui sont
multicolores donc le camp français
lui-même portes du couleurs et l'autre
qui est très intéressante qui était fait
par fendi avec beaucoup de brio
c'est une espace négatif dans le
compenser donc pour expliquer si on
imagine que ici c'était compenser cet
espace là ils ont fait une compenser où
il y à une début et ensuite il y à une
vide et ensuite de compenser continue et
je trouvais que ça c'était un traçantes
et moi même dans les années qui vient je
vais explorer une mariage entre une
talons et le compenser donc il y à déjà
à la maison martin margiela qui a fait
des trompé et je trouve que cette
trompette chalon sur le compenser avec
quelque chose d'intéressant tu nous
cette année reed parry on aimerait voir
si on peut pas le pousser un tout petit
peu plus le compenser en 2013 a vraiment
toute la place à une girl in par les
allées mariage donc chaque endroit où on
serait sur l'herbe et on veut pas que
notre talent on perd cela seul le
compenser le choix logique
avant tout moi parmi toutes celles que
je vois ce soit celle ci celle là celle
là c'est que malgré le fait que ce soit
plein c'est qu'elle soit la plus légère
possible quand on la regarde on sait
finalement c'est un modèle qui est fin
c'est un modèle qui est qui et qui va
affiner toujours la silhouette donc bien
la choisir pour moi c'est vraiment
trouver quelque chose qui soit qu'ils
soient fins et confortable voilà c'est
les deux choses ont vraiment essentiel
et quels sont vos conseils look pour
porter ça qu'on pense et moi je vois une
un pantalon smoking un peu cigarettes
fin avec vraiment enfin compenser assez
important plus tôt dans les 12 13 cm une
petite veste assez courte est tout
simplement un chemisier blanc et
finalement quand on a une tenue comme
celle ci qui est extrêmement simple
tout est dans le jeu de la chaussure
parce que c'est finalement la pièce
maîtresse de cette tenue là ça va être
le compenser et la hauteur qui fait que
cette tenue là ne va pas est classée
donc moi pour la compenser je la vois
comme ça dans un thème à billets et
sinon je la vois mal était avec des
produits comme celui ci où finalement
c'est un produit passe partout qu'on
peut mettre vraiment tous les jours
vieux jeans pantalons c'est vraiment un
produit qui se marient finalement avec
beaucoup beaucoup de choses et
l'avantagent chesneau du fait que ce
soit assez abordable on n'est pas obligé
d'avoir une paire pour la saison et on
peut en avoir beaucoup plus que ça alors
petit récapitulatif les conseils de nos
professionnels
mme edan n'hésitez plus pour être
présents dans ce musée
les pales ont les plus hauts quand la
plate forme à l'avant est là pour vous
aider
n'hésitez pas à vous donner un maximum
d'alluré en prenant de la hauteur
les couleurs électriques le bleu le
jaune les paillettes
elles auront pour effet d'attirer les
regards et d'affirmer votre originalité
le smoking en portant une tenue stricte
ou classique
vous créez le contraste et mettez ainsi
l'accent sur l'originalité de vos
chaussures
en revanche éviter
l'accumulation de différence entre la
plateforme et la chaussure elle même
varier les goûts et les couleurs oui
mais attention à ne pas fournir trop
d'informations dans tous les modèles
plus légers
bien que la partie responsable du poids
soit généralement situés sous les pieds
il faut tout de même pouvoir lever les
chambres pour avancer ne prenez donc pas
de risque de devoir laisser dans le
placard une jolie paire de chaussures
parce qu'elle n'est pas confortable
la chaussure compenser remporte tous les
suffrages
elle est à la fois bobo disco bcbg et
l'adhérence au sol est inversement
proportionnelle à la hauteur de la
semelle et quelle drôle de curiosité
cette shopping vénitienne qui transforme
et la femme en véritable statut
totalement dépendante de ses serviteurs
on considère souvent à tort que la mode
actuelle est peu pratique et bien je
suis bien content de ne pas avoir
apporté ce type de chopines plus
sérieusement pour choisir votre paire de
compensées
ne surestimez pas votre équilibre
choisissez-la avec un vrai talon c'est à
dire l'avant du pied plus près du sol
que l'arrière une hauteur raisonnable
est entre 3 et 10 cm mais ce sont
surtout les brides sur le corps de la
chaussure qui vont être déterminantes
votre pied doit être bien maintenue et
pour le style on choisira plutôt des
pièces large pour ne pas donner un effet
jambes ultra fine et pied de mammouth
sauf si vous optez volontairement pour
ce style face on est au tout y est dans
ce cas porter une blouse large en eau
pour équilibrer votre silhouette
à bientôt pour de nouvelles aventures
sur histoire de souliers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]